a super interesting story for you
yesterday a campaign staffer for Michael
Bloomberg's campaign showed up at my
house in Massachusetts just canvassing
the neighborhood and the reason that
this is interesting is that I was just
telling you two days ago that although
it's not likely that Michael Bloomberg
is going to get the nomination his best
strategy would be to forget about the
first four primaries and just pour money
and resources into the Super Tuesday
States Super Tuesday of course is the
day it's the first day where you have a
bunch of primaries in one day and this
March third is Super Tuesday in this
election cycle we will be having the
following primaries on that day Alabama
Arkansas California Colorado
Maine Massachusetts Minnesota North
Carolina Oklahoma Tennessee Texas Utah
Vermont and Virginia so Massachusetts is
on that list it's a Super Tuesday state
and I spoke to the guy for a little
while he didn't say Bloomberg is
ignoring the first four primary states
but he did say that based on what he has
seen there's not much talk about
Bloomberg having a big ground game in
Iowa New Hampshire Nevada and South
Carolina but that he sees that the focus
seems to be states like Massachusetts
and other Super Tuesday States now I'm
also getting reports that Michael
Bloomberg is funneling money I mean just
pouring buckets and buckets of money
into YouTube ads particularly for people
who are accessing YouTube from those
Super Tuesday states so it actually does
seem like the Bloomberg strategy that I
sort of mentioned on Monday is exactly
the calculation that Michael Bloomberg
has made and the reality is it's worked
so far since I talked about Michael
Bloomberg two days ago he's up another
half of a point Bloomberg now is
averaging eight nationally Bloomberg is
starting to build the lead on Pete Budaj
edge and pushing more solidly into
fourth place so what you have to
understand is that if Bloomberg's
trajectory continues by the time of
Super Tuesday especially if Elizabeth
Warren keeps
losing momentum and doesn't get any wins
in the first four states Bloomberg could
be tied for third place by the time
Super Tuesday arrives I hate money in
politics I think it's corrosive I think
it's toxic I want to see the system
absolutely upended destroyed and taken
apart but the way that Michael Bloomberg
is using the system to build support
seems strategically sound and compare
you know there have been all these
candidates that have just been hanging
around for months and months and months
Bloomberg announces his campaign late
very late and for two months just pours
money into YouTube ads and TV ads and he
passes a lot of people who have been
running for a very long time look at you
know Tulsi Gabbard has been running for
so long
Bloomberg rockets past her Tom Styer if
Tom Styer running a by my way in sort of
campaign Bloomberg coming in spending
more money rocketing past
Tom Styer Amy Klobuchar has been around
for a while she even was endorsed by the
New York Times
along with Elizabeth Warren Bloomberg
Rockets past Amy Klobuchar Andrew yang
has fallen behind a Michael Bloomberg
and now Michael Bloomberg is more than a
point ahead of Pete Budaj edge in the
national polling so again the strategy I
outlined would be let Bernie and Biden
fight out those first few states because
remember if Bernie wins them or if Biden
wins them or if they split them the
margins of victory are going to end up
with Biden and Bernie having a similar
number of Delegates after those first
four primaries when you get to Super
Tuesday it's still going to be wide open
because remember you get delegates in
these first four primaries as long as
you get 15% of the vote you get some
delegates so if Bernie beats Biden by 10
in every state of those first four
Bernie will be winning going into Super
Tuesday but it'll be a lead that could
disappear instantly depending on Super
Tuesday results the opposite is true if
if whether Biden or Bernie win you are
going to see them very close a number of
Delegates going into Super Tuesday
so what Bloomberg appears to be doing is
go right to Super Tuesday pour money in
to those
States maybe he can get up to 15 in a
few of those and again if he keeps
gaining on Elizabeth Warren he can
justify staying in well beyond Super
Tuesday you're almost guaranteed to see
the likes of steyr and Tulsi and maybe
even yang and or clover chars start to
drop out as they get zero delegates
remember if you don't get 15% in a
primary you get 0 delegates 0 not you
know if you get 10% you don't get 10% of
the delegates you get none so you're
going to see candidates start to drop
out and this Michael Bloomberg strategy
could actually work to keep him in okay
now let me do the normal caveat so I got
5 angry emails when I did this Monday
saying David you support Bloomberg now I
am NOT supporting Bloomberg I don't
believe Bloomberg is going to be the
nominee but if you said to me David
you've got a bet a hundred bucks right
now do you bet a hundred bucks on
Bloomberg or Budaj edge being the
nominee I say Bloomberg if you say David
take a bet is it going to be Bloomberg
or Amy Klobuchar I'm betting on
Bloomberg and if you look at the betting
numbers on predict wise and look at how
people are placing bets on who they
believe will be the nominees Bloomberg's
in third it's Bernie followed by Biden
and then it's Bloomberg that the money
thinks will be the most likely
candidates most likely candidate to be
the nominee after Bernie and Biden that
definitely tells us something he's
adopting the exact strategy we talked
about on Monday and he is gaining
support as a result he may even be at 9%
by the time the first votes are cast on
Monday we will continue to follow it I
know that the David Pakman show audience
is full of curious and creative people
who love learning new things and
bettering themselves and that's why I'm
so excited to tell you about one of our
sponsors Skillshare the vibrant online
learning community that offers thousands
of classes on almost any topic you can
imagine and you'll get full access to
the entire library of classes for two
entire months free when you go to david
pakman.com slash skill all of the
classes are taught by experts in their
fields they've got classes on drawing
painting photography video editing web
design book keep
Marketing personal productivity doesn't
even scratch the surface I recently took
a class about photography if anybody
follows me on Instagram you know that my
photography skills leave much to be
desired and it was great I got so much
out of it and hopefully you will see the
fruits of me taking that class reflected
in my Instagram pictures sooner than
later they have classes for every skill
level whether you're wanting to get
better at something you already have
experience with you want to learn
something totally new to you you set
your own pace classes are usually less
than an hour long they're divided up
into bite-size segments so you can
easily fit them into your schedule make
2020 a year where you explore new skills
deep in existing passions get lost in
creativity Skillshare really makes it
easier than ever Skillshare memberships
are less than ten bucks a month and that
gives you access to the thousands of
classes they offer but everybody in the
David Pakman show audience gets a
Skillshare membership totally free for
two whole months just go to david
pakman.com slash skill that's david
pakman.com slash s ki ll